[Musique]
c
l'histoire merci ceci est une histoire
vraie famille à 12 ans c'est un petit
garçon tout meilhon il vient de cocody
un des quartiers les plus huppés
d'abidjan en côte d'ivoire pour ceux qui
connaissent pas sami en sixième
les fans des gps il a des goûts versée à
l'école et surtout il est ni une passion
pour la géolocalisation
si comme à 14 ans l ancien de c'est un
peu plus compliqué pour elle n'avance
pas trop elle son truc
elle veut devenir amazon si j'avais pas
me rencontrer
sani sept mois auparavant je serais
passé à côté de nous c'est que si kamati
et rencontrer sami avec d'autres jeunes
les jeunes qui avaient entre 12 et 17
ans qui avait commis des braquages des
viols qui avait tué ça me faisait pas
trop le malin dans ce groupe là il avait
utilisé sa passion pour la
géolocalisation pour identifier des
maisons de luxe et l'avant veille des
grandes car les cambriolages les des
cerveaux j'ai rencontré sur le terrain
de basket la maison d'arrêt de
correction de la vision
il savait pas trop ce qu'il faisait là
il m'a demandé de l'appeler ses parents
aient pu dire qu'il était désolé qu'ils
savaient pas ce qui est vert
qui sait pas pourquoi il avait fait ça
j'avais pas le droit de garder contact
avec les enfants
j'avais parlera de contacter les parents
je les connaissais pas je savais que je
ne reverrai probablement jamais servi l
époque on m'avait invité pour que je
parle d'un programme qu'on développe au
togo et en côte d'ivoire qu'on appelait
millet dont il est ou qui veut dire
voilà on utilisait le basket pour
apprendre aux jeunes comment grandir
ensemble
elana vainqueur face à la situation de
ces jeunes surtout qui disaient qu'ils
savaient pas pourquoi il avait commis
ces actes
je me suis dit 'ça suffit pas d'utiliser
veut le basket pour permettre aux jeunes
de grandir ensemble
j'avais la conviction qu'on pouvait
faire plus et à partir de là j'ai
embarqué tous mes coaches qui
travaillent avec moi je leur dis venez
on va explorer j'ai une conviction mais
je ne sais pas où ça va nous mener et
m'ont dit on y va
ce que je vais vous partez à jouer
aujourd'hui ces deux dernières années où
on allait explorer plein de choses on a
posé plein d'hypothèses on s'est trompé
et ça nous a permis de comprendre des
choses
amazon définition c'est une femme
guerrière dans la bouche de ces jeunes
filles et voulait devenir une femme
guerrière elle voulait faire la guerre
et voulait tuer pourquoi tu veux tuer je
ne sais pas pourquoi coach sept jeunes
filles s'entraînent sur ce terme un
terrain qu'on a construit en 2014 pour
permettre aux filles et aux garçons de
couver mon village le village au modem
de participer au programme il est tôt il
n'y avait pas terrain de basket à
prouver c'est un basket nous a coûté 5
millions le jour de la construction le
jour de l'inauguration les personnes
sont venues nous voir en disant pourquoi
vous n'avez pas mis cet argent dans des
choses plus importantes comme l'eau
l'électricité
même si vous voulez contribuer à
l'éducation pourquoi pas construire une
école pourquoi pas le faire des choses
plus importantes dans ma tête je suis y
va le temps va prouver que c'est pas si
mal de construire un terrain parce
qu'elle est de permettre de connecter
ses jeunes aux jeunes des autres villes
pour qu'eux aussi découvre des choses
mais ces vacances 2010 est donc
sainement après l'expérience à la main
comme j'ai dû trop envie de rigoler
quand une fille me dit qu elle envie de
venir amazon etc un habitué et surtout
que ça va s'arrêter là on va avoir deux
classes grossesse des filles pour
lesquels on peut l école on veut qu'elle
avance on sait que c'est difficile on a
construit ce terrain ça crée une
dynamique et on s'est dit on va vous
accompagner pour aller plus loin ce que
je veux que les femmes réussissent à
moins qu'il a contribué à mon éducation
elle a tout
et vous c'est fille on va chercher les
poux thèse la plus simple qu est-ce qui
va pas qu'est ce qui fait qu'elle
n'avance pas quel est le cadre familial
dans lequel elles vivent est-ce qu'il va
revenir à chaque fois c'est que le papa
n'est pas à la maison qu'elle va de pair
et on va se renseigner avec les coaches
des autres villes pour voir cette
histoire de père et un foyer sur deux
dans les villes on travaille le papa
n'est pas là où sont nos papas et c'est
l'absence de papa qui impacte autant
pourquoi personne n'en parle
y'a vraiment pas de statistiques fiables
est-ce que c'est l'absence du père qui
fait que dauphine avant spa avec nos
cochons a décidé d'en parler
est ce que c'est un tabou on va parler
de nos pères on va se raconter nos
histoires
ils savent être violent
moi je n'ai pas connu mon père moi mon
père est décédé et a été tué puis l'été
pour les vivent mon père alcoolique il
était abusif des choses dont on parle
pas mais on sait que ça fait mal et je
dérangeais par live j'ai présenté mon
père mon père est un leader politique en
envoyant france pendant qu'il fait beau
il mener son combat et j'ai vécu loin de
lui j'ai eu beau basket j'ai eu ma vie
et je me souciais pas que son absence
pesé et puis en 2010 j'ai reçu cet appel
pour m'annoncer qu'il était malade et là
j'ai eu peur j'ai pas eu peur pour lui
j'ai peur pour moi j'avais plein de
questions je me suis dit si ce monsieur
bah je vais rester là sans mes réponses
et on va se connecter avec mon père on
va recommencer à parler de tout je lui
posais plein de questions on va faire
des interviews et on va se parler à
chaque fois qu'on va se parler je
poserai tellement de questions comme si
c'était la dame en flagrance voyez à mon
père est costaud il reste en vie pendant
très longtemps il est toujours là
l'année dernière on a franchi un palier
j'ai été sélectionné pour un programme
de la fondation barack obama en afrique
du sud
et quand je suis revenu ni d'un trade et
il m'a demandé si c'est mon histoire de
basket qui m'avait emmené jusqu'en
afrique du sud voir barack obama il est
non à des problèmes au togo on fait des
choses et puis c'est toi qui vas voir
obama et avant que j'y réponds mon père
va dire un mot magique il va dire tu
sais quoi mais j'ai toujours su qu'il y
avait un truc qui sort dans ce monde
c'est l'amour waouh il m'avait montrait
beaucoup d'affection depuis quelques
années elle m'avait jamais parlé d'un
moment il m'avait jamais dit ça en fait
quand ça se passe comme ça si s'était
arrêté là l'histoire du basket
je leur ai donné la réponse que je donne
à chaque fois qu'on pose la question de
pourquoi je mène ce projet je leur ai
dit on a mis ce terrain de basket
ça m'a permis d'avoir des filles et les
garçons qui jouent ensemble ça a permis
de connecter des filets garçons et
riches et les pauvres parce qu'on a eu
des hauts et des jeunes du lycée
français de british school et jeunes qui
venaient de partout les jeunes qui
venaient de volcans des jeunes qui
venaient de se coller du nord du sud et
moi j'ai jamais vu un outil qui
permettait de rassembler autant de
personnes est pour moi une nation se
construit comme ça permettra les gens
qui se connaissent pas qu'ils pensent
qu'ils sont différents et deux grosses
loyers et les éduquer ensemble mais
comme mon père a utilisé le mot magique
comme il a parlé d'un mot il a tendu la
main à je devais aussi aller et je vais
parler de ce qu'on m'aime comme
recherche
je vais parler de ces histoires de père
absent cette histoire de père absent qui
nous emmener loin en à creuser c'est
quelque chose qui m'a
le fusille est-ce que c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on tient là et je vais parler
de ça un psychiatre un monsieur qui
avait fondé la psychiatrie au togo
aujourd'hui la 93 ans certains
n'écoutent pas les vieux monsieur moi
j'aime bien les écouter c'est des sages
ils sont remplis de sucre elle et je
vais parler de cette histoire de père
absent
il m'a dit oui c'est quelque chose qui
existe on en parle en psychiatrie tienne
absence physique
une absence émotionnel c'est un impact
sur les enfants forcément mais on peut
s'en sortir sans trêve il m'a dit
regarde toi et m'a dit je te casse pas
la tête avec cette histoire parce que
nos sociétés africaines
on n'était pas les enfants de nos
parents on était les enfants de la
communauté
et quand le père n'était pas là où les
parents n'étaient pas là on pouvait
trouver quelqu'un dans la communauté
une figure attachante et m'a dit j'ai
beaucoup de projets que tu mènes parce
que tu es en train de recréer une
communauté et vous pouvez être la figure
attachante pour ses enfants à condition
que vous soyez capable de les renvoyer à
eux mêmes les renvoyer m
oui ne pas leur dire ce qu'il doit faire
les faire réfléchir
mais cette notion je ne vais pas perdu
et m'a permis de répondre à mon père qui
m'a parlé d'amour et je lui ai dit que
l'amour commence par l'amo pour soi
l'acceptation de soi l'estimé de soi
toutes ces notions dont on parle
aujourd'hui mais qu'au fond on comprend
pas vraiment ce que ça veut dire
parce que c'est des choses qu'on peut
pas expliquer si les choses qui peuvent
se vivre et ça m'a fait penser à ces
activités quand même par le basket
mes coaches m'ont toujours dit que le
pen est plus important c'était pas le
panier dans lequel ont marqué c'est elle
bannit qu'on défend bec et on sait pas
pourquoi mais on doit le faire ils ont
toujours dit on gagne des titres avec la
défense on gagne des matchs avec l'attak
c'est la même chose dans ma vie
pour tous on veut tous marqué et on sait
même pas pourquoi on court au cours au
concours ne veux pas revenir en arrière
on veut pas s'affronter et nous on a
joué le jeu avec les coachs on s'est
affrontées on a passé des séances avec
un psychologue
on était quinze 15 coach je peux vous
assurer que beaucoup avaient peur mais
au final c'était très drôle d'affronter
serveurs de comprendre que ans traverse
tous la même chose ça nous a rendu
beaucoup plus humain et on est retourné
au contact de nos enfants de nos jeunes
et à chaque fois qu'il nous parlait on
essaie de les renvoyer vers eux mêmes
aussi bien sur le terrain qu'en dehors
tous leurs problèmes et ça il en effet
magique ça paraît anodin et renvoyer une
personne à elle même
ça peut lui changer son existence notre
amazon en la renvoyant elle même elle a
trouvé le courage de passer le pdl en
sixième c'est vrai qu'à 15 ans elle en
sixième est le retard mais c'est sa
victoire elle n y croient elle avance et
sur terol a trouvé sa place c'est la
meilleure joueuse et participera au
championnat national qu'on va organiser
dans quelques mois elle va porter
l'équipe de couvet une de nos fille qui
a eu un gros cesse avec son enfant c'est
compliqué au début les gens m'en rejeté
en à dinan elle va l'assumer
on peut avoir un enfant tu aurais
l'assumer a avancé la trouver le courage
de retourner à l'école elle en première
et veut devenir hôtesse de l'air elle va
y arriver
la deuxième a eu des jumeaux avoir des
jumeaux à 17 ans c'est compliqué très
compliqué elle a dû arrêter l'école elle
a déjà perdu deux ans mais on a appris
on a appris avec ces jeunes
aujourd'hui comme on nous l'a dit on est
il qu à ou aller dans les maisons nos
coachs y vont quand les parents le
demandent quand ils sont dépassés
on va dans les cases et on parle de
biais d'ag o'shea on parle avec les
enfants on sait ce qui se passe dans
leur tête parce qu'on a tous été des
enfants
on a tous été des jeunes on sait ce qui
se passe et surtout à notre époque avec
internet
ça m'a encore plus vite ça va beaucoup
trop vite
il faut accompagner ces jeunes si je
parlais que des filles je laisserai de
côté une partie du problème
les garçons les gars on avance souvent
l'écho d'une histoire de grossesse et
les filles et ça se voit elles peuvent
pas jouer les garçons les avances il
avance dans ses bagages en souffrance
aussi alphonse sur la photo un pas connu
son père son père est là mais il
s'occupa lui il en a longtemps souffert
aujourd'hui il parle de idy qui leur fut
l'un d'eux père vivant l'accepter bonne
et musique est difficile et celle
d'énergie qu'au début pensées négatives
il a utilisé pour avancer c'est un des
premiers jeunes qu'on a et d en 2014 il
a intégré la flûte à leader ship academy
en 2015 en afrique du sud
puis il est parti aux états unis à lui
verser de rochester l'année dernière il
était en stage à morgan stanley
cette année il va faire un stage chez
microsoft c'est un génie et si vous
l'avez lu
beaucoup auraient pu penser qu'il était
fou qui est des différents essais je
rencontre tous les jours tous les jours
il veut revenir à lomé dans quelques
mois il veut partager son expérience
pour lui la connaissance de soi c'est la
clé et veut discuter avec les jeunes il
veut parler avec eux et ces jeunes sont
en train de prendre les choses en main
on va passer devant un éducateur à 30
d'ici quelques mois on va voir des
bureaux sur le boulevard on a construit
un sens dans le village vous pouvez pour
améliorer le suivi
j'ai mis longtemps avant de comprendre
ce que c'était que la connaissance de
soi mais c'est difficile pour les gens
juste d'écouter et ça fait peur à santé
mentale est une barrière invisible
et pourtant derrière y'a plein de choses
ya des miracles qui se passe ce que
j'aimerais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut croire en
soi
hier j'ai posé la question à monsieur
gilles a day
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait qu'il a réussi et
l'humilité de dire que c'est parce qu'il
a beaucoup échoué et c'est exactement ce
qu'on nous apprend sport et cei et ses
essais et essayent j'ai quitté mon
travail à quelques il ya trois ans ça
fait peur à moi même dit mais qu'est ce
que tu nous fais le salaire que tu as tu
sais ce que celle j maman je vois
quelque chose tu vois quelque chose et
je pense qu'on le voit tous on le sait
tous c'est juste qu'on n'ose pas on se
met des barrières tout seul on a peur
avec une passion avec une communauté
avec une figure attachante et avec des
opportunités à quel que soit là où on va
en train de transformer cette peur des
jeunes en espoirs et il avance il croit
en des choses que là nous les adultes
aura plus et quand on me demande
pourquoi tu as espoirs dans un monde où
il ya un repli sur soi agissez parce que
je suis au contact des enfants c'est
parce que je me suis mis au service de
ceux ci ses enfants et c'est quelque
chose qui va dans les deux sens quand tu
donnes le vrai un mot il sut tout blanc
tout laurent aimez vous parvenez vous si
j'ai pas pardonner mon père si on
m'avait appelé en 2010 qui était décédé
il doit pas répondu à mes questions et
ça c'est un des plus grands défis pour
vous que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est de vous réconcilier avec vous même
parce que quand je suis entré à la maca
je pensais que j'allais apprendre à ces
jeunes je préfère mon projet il est où
en fait avant d'être avec les autres il
faudrait que soi-même et entre 1000 et
tout est mis les do happen grande
différence l'afrique est riche croyant m
merci beaucoup jean-luc haïti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]